Prof: Okay everybody,
let's start in.
Today I want to talk about
green building and the
opportunity to also think about
the laws that surround green
building,
and also the energy
implications of green building
standards.
And I'd like to also address
the history by having you think
about the way that these
standards have evolved over
time,
particularly the evolution of
certification programs.
So the idea of certification,
I want you to think about it
quite broadly at the outset.
Because it basically implies
that certain standards are being
applied to something.
It might be a product,
it could be a service.
It could be a neighborhood,
a city.
So that the idea that there is
an expert group that would
review something,
whether or not it's your
academic preparation and
performance,
or whether or not it's a
building's performance,
and then certify it,
give it a symbol.
It would rank it relative to
others.
One obvious example would be
looking at a GPA on a
transcript.
Well, what we'll see after
today's lecture is that the
green building programs that
have evolved in Europe,
in the United States,
and Australia,
they really are based on that
same kind of concept.
So how would you rate the
environmental and health
responsibility and energy
efficiency of new building
standards?
How would they apply or how
might they apply to renovation
projects?
So I'm basically going to use
the lecture today to share with
you an overview of a paper that
will be published in about two
weeks that is a critique of the
U.S.
Green Building Council's
program known as LEED.
So I'd like you also think
about the importance of the
building sector in its demand
for energy in the United States.
Buildings consume seventy-six
percent of the U.S.
electricity and emit almost
half of the nation's greenhouse
gases.
So that how we manage the
future of building and
development will very much
influence the intensity of
energy demand.
Keep in mind also that the U.S.
consumes more energy than any
other country in the world,
and U.S.
consumers consume nearly
twenty-five percent of the
world's energy and only accounts
for five percent of the world's
population.
So that our energy demand is
increasing at about two percent
per year.
So why might that be?
I mean, obviously,
we're changing our behavior.
We're changing our technology
and our dependence on
technology.
And also the environments that
we shape around us have enormous
implications for energy that
often are not well understood,
for a variety of reasons.
You, for example,
probably have no understanding
of how your daily behavior and
variability in your behavior
might influence your daily
energy demand.
The way that you manage your
computers,
the way that you manage your
windows,
your air exchange between
indoor and outdoor environments,
the way you manage lights,
whether or not you have a car
on campus.
If you do, how often do you use
it?
Where do you park it?
What's its fuel efficiency?
So thinking about how to keep
track of an individual's energy
demand is really not in most
people's minds clearly defined.
So as I just said,
the contribution to the climate
change problem and our
dependence on foreign oil is
really very much dependent upon
the way that we build and the
way that we set up standards to
encourage energy efficiency.
So thirty-nine percent of
CO_2 emissions come
from the building sector,
forty percent of total energy
consumption,
thirteen percent of water
and about fifteen percent of
gross domestic product per year
is associated with the building
sector.
Think about the different
patterns of growth and how the
different patterns of growth and
neighborhood development
influence the way that we use
energy.
These houses are not connected,
so they can't gain any benefit
for heat conservation by having
adjoining walls.
They all had their own yards.
And in fact,
if you think about how people
move around in these kinds of
neighborhoods,
you'd realize that because of
the fencing in the back yard and
without gates that go between
all the different lots it would
be quite normal for somebody to
get in a car and then drive all
the way around the block to take
their kids to somebody else's
house that might be less than a
baseball throw away.
So that patterns of development
encourage patterns of transit
that have just an enormous
influence on the way that we
consume electricity,
but also petroleum products.
So think also about the cities
in the nation that during the
1990s and over the past decade
have experienced some of the
most rapid rates of growth.
Well, these include Las Vegas.
And Las Vegas is expanding into
the desert in a manner and at a
density that is suburban,
it's sprawling.
But it's unusual in Las Vegas
because of the arid environment.
So that the every house would
likely have a lawn,
the lawn would require
sprinkling.
Many of these houses also,
once they're built out,
would have swimming pools.
So that think about the way
that the use of water demands
energy to not just move it
around,
not just the distribution,
but also filtration and also
the energy that goes into
putting in the infrastructure to
move it around.
Now, on Thursday,
I'm going to come back and talk
more about the new town movement
in the United States and this
problem of managing growth at a
larger scale than today's
lecture,
which is really focused on the
individual buildings.
But it is interesting that a
movement evolved in the 1960s
and 1970s in the United States
to design neighborhoods,
to design whole new communities
in a way that would take into
account some of these problems.
Irvine, California is the
example in this slide.
And you can see the center of
the campus,
but you can also see the large
academic buildings surrounding a
green in the center,
and then in the adjacent areas,
you have recreational
facilities,
but also higher density housing
nearby.
So a very walkable community,
one that is not based on the
idea of segregating land uses,
commercial versus residential
versus industrial versus
recreational.
So that in suburban
Connecticut, you put your kids
in a car and you drive from the
area where you live to where you
work to the recreational area to
dance lessons,
whatever it is.
So that this community was
intentionally designed back in
the '60s and '70s in a way that
would provide for mixed land
uses and offer opportunities for
much increased pedestrian
traffic.
As opposed to suburban areas
around New Haven,
here's an example of a
community about twenty miles
away that many of my colleagues
live in.
And this is zoning at a scale
of about one unit per four to
five acres.
So each of these houses has a
strip of land that reaches back
from it into an area that might
otherwise be common open space.
So that this low-density
development demands even more
time spent in cars and more
fuel.
A good example of a house in a
more rural part of Connecticut.
So keep these things in mind as
you're thinking about your own
behavior,
the way you grew up,
and you try to consider how
your lifestyle choices
influenced your family's
consumption level.
Also, I want you to think about
the idea of size,
and how we are increasingly
dependent upon many consumer
products in our lives that are
larger than they used to be.
And housing is no exception.
So that the average house size
in 2009 is grown to about 2,500
square feet, with about two
point three on average people
per house.
That's really pretty remarkable.
So you know,
roughly 1,000 square feet per
person.
Whereas back in 1950,
the average number of people in
a house was much closer to
three,
a little bit over three with
the post-World War II baby boom,
with a total size of 800 square
feet.
So the house size has grown by
three fold.
In 1970, it grew to 1,500 feet.
So the energy demands of a
larger house like that are
actually quite difficult to
predict if you try to take into
account the diversity of
building materials.
Boy, I apologize for this.
And, you know,
one of you might go outside and
let them know that there's a
lecture going on in here.
That would be really nice.
The construction is creating
also diesel fumes inside the
building.
Many of the garages that you
find in suburban areas also have
grown in size.
So here's an example of a
garage that is actually larger
than the average house size was
back in 1950.
This is probably about a
twenty-two, twenty-three by
thirty foot house.
So that's roughly 1,200 square
feet, pretty interesting.
Now think about the way that
space is laid out.
So here's a studio apartment on
the right hand side.
And you see a dining table,
a kitchenette,
walk-in closet and a bath on
the upper level.
Whereas the base level is
dominated by a garage.
So that we're allocating less
space indoors to our bedrooms
than we are to our auto storage
areas.
Also, many buildings are now
constructed with much more glass
in them than previously.
And the newer high-end
buildings are using special
glass that is designed to
reflect radiation so that it's
not absorbed.
But different glasses are
really designed for different
climatic regions so that some
are more efficient at reflecting
radiation that are used in
southern climates that are
warmer.
And others are more efficient
at providing insulation,
so they've got a barrier in the
interior that basically protects
against heat loss.
So that overall though,
buildings' increased use of
windows has created increased
energy demands.
Also lighting.
And also the way that we have
increasingly designed bathrooms
to have more than one fixture.
So here's an example of a
shower stall that has multiple
showerheads in it,
multiple faucets.
So that water demand is often
increased in bathrooms designed
like this.
Most green building programs
also attempt to regulate the
building materials that are used
in furnishings.
So here's an example of a
bookcase and set of drawers that
seemingly are made out of oak.
But this is actually an oak
veneer.
And if you have been up in
Kroon Hall where the Forestry
and Environmental Studies School
is,
you may know that about seventy
percent of the wood that's on
the interior of this was grown
on Yale property,
on Yale forests.
It also is red oak,
but it's solid red oak.
It's not a veneer.
So what's beneath the veneer?
Here you can see a strip of
pressboard that is faced with a
white oak surface.
But the interior is basically
low-grade wood chips of a
variety of different species
that are compressed together and
they are mixed up in liquid form
with adhesives and then they are
rolled out in a strip and then
cut into a variety of different
sizes.
The adhesives have compounds
that are often proprietary and
even unknown to most who
purchase them or sell them at
building supply houses.
They commonly contain adhesives
that are epoxy resins,
some of which contain
bisphenol-A that we talked about
earlier in the course.
But also formaldehyde is a
component that is commonly used
that is an allergen and it's a
suspected carcinogen.
I'd like you to think too about
the problem of your
understanding.
How could you increase your
understanding of the energy
intensity of your own lifestyle?
Well, here's a pretty good
example of the way that houses
that were built in the 1990s and
previously are metered.
So that this is at your utility
junction box,
where the line comes in from
the road.
This is my meter.
I have the same brand.
And it's got five dials on it.
And you might think,
well that's not that tough to
figure out.
But if you walk up to it,
you'll see that the dials
actually have the numbers that
on the first dial on the left,
it goes from lowest to highest
in a clockwise motion.
But in the second it goes from
lowest to highest in a
counterclockwise motion.
So they switch on as you move
across the screen.
So this is actually a very
difficult thing to keep track
of.
Now also, you might wonder
well, how would I find out how
my variance in behavior,
how I manage my computers or my
lights or my water consumption,
or how big a refrigerator I
have, how is that going to
affect my electric bill?
It's really hard to figure it
out given this kind of a
metering system.
Because if you can decipher
what the meter says,
you'll only get a total figure
for your consumption.
Now, this has created an
opportunity for people to design
a variety of smart meters that
keep track of energy intake and
use and how it's distributed in
a house for different purposes.
So that I tried to figure this
out given my dial meter at my
home and ended up turning off
absolutely everything in the
house and then starting up
appliances one by one.
So I'd start the refrigerator
and I'd turn the refrigerator
off.
I'd start a dryer,
start a dishwasher,
but that would be the only
appliance that I would have
running.
But you can imagine,
every time you plug in one and
then go out to the meter and
take a reading,
come back in,
unplug it and plug in something
else,
it's going to take you a very
long time to figure out where
you're spending your money.
By doing that over a period of
about eight hours,
I was able to save about
twenty-five percent of my
average monthly energy bill by
figuring out how to restrict
access or fully turn off
different appliances in the
house.
Building products and building
construction is normally
regulated by a variety of
building codes,
many of which have been adopted
internationally.
So that these codes apply to
materials,
they apply to electrical
systems, they apply to energy
sources,
fire prevention,
mechanical, heating and
ventilation and air condition
systems,
plumbing.
They even apply to historical
sites and in earthquake-prone
parts of the country,
they have a code that is
distinctive in California for
earthquake stability.
So that these codes evolved
originally as being voluntary,
so that they were not formally
adopted by state or local
governments.
But now you'll find most states
do have similar kinds of
building codes.
And they were originally
designed to promote
understanding of the
functionality and the safety and
the durability of different
kinds of products,
also to promote truth in
labeling.
But they never really were
designed to promote
environmental responsibility,
health protection or energy
efficiency.
So that the green building
movement was really ripe for a
brand new certification system
that would apply a variety of
different kinds of standards.
And the three programs that
I'll mention today include the
LEED program by the U.S.
Green Building Council,
the BREEAM program in the
United Kingdom,
and the Green Star program in
Australia.
And the BRE Environmental
Assessment Method is perhaps the
best known in the world right
now, and it's the most widely
adopted throughout Europe.
And it set standards for best
practices in sustainable design
and has become really a de facto
measure used to describe a
building's environmental
performance within the European
Union.
Australia has the Green Star
program,
which is national,
it's also voluntary,
that evaluates construction,
environmental design,
and has been particularly well
developed for commercial
structures,
especially office buildings in
downtown districts,
where about eleven percent of
the buildings have been
constructed and certified under
the program.
So its purposes are to first of
all, try to figure out a common
language and common definition
for what "green"
is.
So that before the National
Organic Food Standard was
adopted,
there was no national
consistency in the definition of
what organic food was,
so it varied by certification
scheme.
The Green Star program also
sets measurement standards.
So that there is a common
approach to measuring say energy
consumption or the capacity of
different building materials,
such as electrical conduit.
And they also promoted a whole
building design,
so that one would think about
not just the individual
components,
the individual building
materials or the different
systems,
and by systems,
I mean like water supply,
electrical supply,
perhaps the heating and
ventilation system,
plumbing.
But to figure out how to put
all of these components together
in a way that would minimize the
long-term adverse affect on
environmental quality or human
health or energy loss.
So this idea that one would
think about building materials
and the style of design in a way
that would consider the ultimate
product lifecycle,
this is really a pretty new
idea in the building industry.
So that, you know,
what's going to happen to that
PVC pipe that exists in your
house when your building gets
torn down?
What's going to happen to the
copper piping that delivers the
water?
Well, the PVC pipe,
you can almost be assured is
going to be either burned or
it's going to be discarded in a
landfill.
But the copper piping is highly
likely to be recycled because of
its market value.
So differences in these
programs are normally associated
with the way that they allocate
credits or points to buildings
for different purposes.
But they really are quite
similar in their attempt to
promote energy conservation,
concern for chemical life
cycles, as well as human health.
So the Green Building Council
evolved, beginning in 1993.
And this is what I want to
focus on now for the remainder
of the session.
And it is a voluntary nonprofit
organization that has no
government affiliation,
although it was started by a
grant from the U.S.
Energy Department.
So this is created with a board
of directors that include people
that have expertise in
architecture and engineering as
well as some of the largest
development firms,
construction firms,
in the nation.
There are really not a number
of people on this board or on
the staff that have deep
environmental or health
expertise.
And its orientation has
predominantly been to promote
energy efficiency.
They claim that the benefits of
this leadership in energy and
environmental design,
which is what the LEED acronym
stands for,
that it has three predominant
purposes.
One is to promote environmental
quality.
The second is economic
development to basically
stimulate a new type of building
and new building materials that
are more environmentally
responsible.
Sorry about the noise.
And also to promote healthy
lifestyles within buildings and
communities.
And by healthy lifestyles
within a building,
I'll give you one example.
A colleague of mine works at
the Centers for Disease Control
in Atlanta, and they have a
relatively new building.
And just as a healthy lifestyle
attribute,
they decided that instead of
putting a staircase in the back
of the building and the elevator
right near the front door when
people walked in,
that they would reverse that.
So the elevator was put in the
back and the staircase was
surrounded by glass panels that
made it really light,
sunlight steams through and
attractive.
So that people,
when they go into the building,
normally walk up the stairs,
a seven- or eight- story
building.
So that this individual who
directed the National Center for
Environmental Health told me
that he and his staff,
that nobody uses the elevator,
everybody goes up and down the
stairs.
So it saves energy,
the elevator is not used much.
And it also is healthy,
it's burning up calories.
So that the purpose of LEED
falls into a variety of
categories.
One is sustainable sites,
another is water efficiency,
another is energy and
atmosphere, another is materials
and resources.
The fifth is indoor
environmental quality,
and the fourth is really
creativity and innovation in
design.
So I mean, you might image
different categories might be a
part of a system such as this.
But there are interesting
questions about the relative
importance that these categories
should be assigned.
Should you be assigned as much
about the nature of the site
that's chosen for building?
Whether or not it's remote and
is going to be in a green field
area as opposed to the site that
might be hazardous and
contaminated?
So that the Kroon Hall up on
Prospect Street across from the
Whale, Kroon Hall was built on a
highly contaminated site.
So that a former power plant
was there,
and a lot of work had to be
done to clean that site up to
remove contaminated debris as
well as other infrastructure,
the heating and electrical and
hot air conduits that go from
the power plant up to Science
Hill,
particularly Kline Science
Tower.
So that the idea that you would
give more credits to a building
program that would not chew up
undisturbed areas that are in
say the suburbs,
you'd give more credit to those
that were actively going to
restore sites,
is an interesting concept.
The certification program that
I'm going to talk about today
has to do with new construction
and renovation.
Although there are other
programs that LEED has,
for example a program for
schools, a program for homes.
So that in this program,
there are a hundred base points
plus ten possible bonus points.
And there are different levels
of certification that can be
achieved.
So if you achieve forty to
forty-nine points,
you are certified.
Up to fifty to fifty-nine
points, you're given a silver
certification,
a gold is sixty to
seventy-nine,
and then platinum is eighty to
a hundred and ten points.
You could imagine a variety of
different strategies here that
would hold the bar higher for
the base level of certification
or perhaps hold the bar higher
for only the platinum level.
The Kroon Building was just
certified to be a platinum
building, as an example.
So these are the different
kinds of certification programs
that LEED has beneath its
umbrella.
And as I mentioned,
the first one,
new construction and
renovation, is the subject of
today's talk.
But also, schools,
core and shell components of
buildings,
neighborhood development,
retail facilities,
healthcare facilities,
commercial interiors,
and homes.
Sorry, I've got a couple of
duplicate slides here.
So I'd like you to think about
sustainable sites.
Credits can be awarded for
building on previously developed
land.
They give additional credits
for minimizing impacts on
ecosystems and waterways,
for promoting landscaping that
is regionally appropriate.
So if for example,
in the slide that I showed in
Arizona,
if you were trying to get LEED
certification for a new project,
you would need to be very
careful about the kind of
landscaping that you put in,
making certain that it wasn't
water dependent.
Whether or not the building
site encourages access to public
transportation,
so proximity say,
to a rail station would improve
the number of points.
The control of storm water
runoff, and erosion.
So as an example there,
Kroon Hall has a very large
gutter that overhangs the south
side and funnels water down into
that water garden that is on the
eastern side of the structure.
Then that water moves through a
filtration plant inside the
building,
and then is recycled into gray
water,
so that it is used for removal
of human waste in the bathrooms.
Well, also, here's an example
of how that building achieved
certain points by the
restoration program,
digging out the old
contaminated lands and
rebuilding.
So for each of these
categories, I'm not going to
spend much time on this.
But for each of the categories,
you can achieve points in
different directions.
And you can imagine that the
way that these points are
allocated category by category
could have a pretty significant
implication for providing
encouragement.
By the way, why would a
developer want to be LEED
certified anyway?
What's the value?
Well, I mentioned one value
that would be to the building
industry at large,
which is creating an incentive
for a new line of products and a
new approach to building design
that would create jobs and cause
the industry to grow generally.
But most developers are in this
because they know that if they
achieve certification and the
property value is higher,
they can demand a premium for
the structure or the complex.
So that in this case,
the sustainable sites category
allows one to seek about
twenty-three percent of total
number of credits that are
possible.
So that these can be awarded
for brownfield redevelopment,
for alternative transportation,
the bike storage area that you
find behind Osborne Laboratory
caused FES to gain additional
points.
The management of storm water,
trying to manage a heat island
effect, reduce that intensity of
heat absorption by creating
green roofs.
There was a green roof that's
on part of that site.
Water efficiency also is a
source of possible points,
about nine percent of the
total.
So that within this category,
appliance efficiency,
fixtures and fittings are good
examples of different ways of
saving water as well as the
landscaping that I mentioned
earlier.
And I wanted to mention a
couple of kind of relatively
recent technological designs.
One is these leverless faucets
that sense your presence,
either by an electronic eye or
sensing heat that causes them to
turn on and off.
And it's kind of interesting.
You know, I have become more
curious about this and watch
people's hand washing behavior,
particularly in places like
airports.
And it's really common to have
a whole array of these things on
a countertop.
And people often have to move
from one the other to get one to
work.
And after that happens a number
of times, people I think are
more likely just to not wash
their hands.
So there's a sanitation problem
that is potentially associated
with it.
If you go into the men's rooms
and look at the flushless
urinals, you will immediately
recognize that there is a
serious problem in Kroon.
And it's led many to argue that
they really would rather make
the tradeoff between the odor in
the bathroom that might
otherwise be managed by
improving the heating and
ventilation system.
So that right now,
no water is used in this
toilet, only a synthetic
compound is put in to try to
maintain its sanitation.
But it often is not as
effective as it is promoted to
be.
So that water efficiency can be
achieved in a variety of ways.
The faucets themselves are
often fitted with restrictions
in flow so that if you're
interested in taking a more
powerful shower,
you'll need to figure out how
to get the flow restrictor out,
which many people do try.
The flow restrictor itself is
governed by local and state
building codes.
And it was kind of interesting
to me, it was an education for
me.
When I wondered,
I asked a plumber who was
installing a new faucet in my
sink,
and I said, you know,
I really would like a larger
rate of flow in this sink so
that I could be more effective
in washing dishes or whatever.
And he said,
well you know,
you really don't understand the
energy implications of not
restricting the flow.
And if you thought about it,
then you'd realize that the
energy costs are really quite
high to move the water to your
home.
And I said, "Well,
I've got my own well."
He said, "Well think about
where the energy is coming from
that causes your pump to lift
the water 600 feet.
And then also think about the
more water that you use,
the more waste you create,
so you're likely to disperse
biological and chemical
contaminants more broadly."
So my plumber gave me a lesson
in environmental behavior that I
thought was quite valuable.
So the majority,
not the majority,
but the highest proportion of
points or credits are awarded
under the LEED program for
energy and atmospheric concerns.
So that new buildings can
obtain points by monitoring
energy consumption,
and this is being pretty
carefully done in Kroon Hall,
as an example.
And the orientation of the
building,
of Kroon, it's facing east to
west,
so that it has more window
space on the south side to
absorb more solar radiation.
It also has solar panels that
run across the south side and a
variety of other saving
techniques.
So that the dominance of energy
and energy conservation in the
LEED certification and credit
program relative to these other
categories is quite interesting.
With respect to materials and
resources, the management of
waste is also more intensely
monitored within a
LEED-certified building.
And when a building is actually
certified, it's not certified
forever, it's certified for a
fixed period of time,
often only a single year.
And a building is not certified
until it can demonstrate that it
has performed at a level of X
during that year.
So it's kind of an interesting
idea.
If a building's heating and
ventilation system malfunctions,
then a year or two down the
road, it's not going to be
recertified.
Indoor environmental quality is
increasingly a concern,
and only fifteen points
compared to about thirty-four
points in the energy category.
Only fifteen points are
allocated for indoor
environmental quality.
Now, what does that mean?
It generally means a concern
for the chemical content of the
indoor environment.
But it also includes the
opportunity to gain points for
natural daylight and views,
and also for acoustical
control, noise control,
so that the situation that
we're experiencing here might be
avoided.
Now, you know,
again, think about the
importance of this in terms of
human chemical exposure given
the fact that we spend so much
time indoors.
You know this diagram is now a
couple of years old.
But in the latter part of the
1990s,
EPA was estimating that about
eighty-six,
eighty-seven percent of time
was spent indoors,
about five percent of time was
spent in a vehicle.
So thinking about the chemical
content of the indoor
environment is important,
especially for certain
subgroups, like kids.
This can be managed in a
variety of ways.
And you could think,
well, the ventilation rate or
the air exchange rate,
indoor to outdoor,
is one way of doing that,
depending upon where your
building is.
So in general,
outdoor air quality is better
than indoor air quality,
unless you live in proximity to
an industrial area or to a
highway.
So that being able to
mechanically and individually
control windows is an important
strategy for managing air
quality.
But also thinking about a
variety of different materials
and compounds that are brought
into the built environment,
so that some compounds and some
products are discouraged under
this program.
So that paints,
for example,
that emit a high level of
volatile organic compounds are
discouraged.
So low emitting paints,
varnishes, polyurethanes,
are now designated.
So that if you look at the can
of oil-based paint,
you'll find that roughly two
and a half pounds of volatile
organic compounds are contained.
Whereas certain paints are now
manufactured with no volatile
organic compounds.
You might also think about the
compact fluorescents that pose
kind of an interesting problem
in that they contain mercury.
So that this is a piece of
personal advice for you,
as you install or remove
compact fluorescents,
be really careful about them.
Because if they break in your
room, it's going to scatter
mercury around,
and the mercury will vaporize.
If it gets into a rug and you
vacuum the rug,
the rug is going to give off
the mercury vapors,
and it will increase the
volatilization rate.
And it will be just about
impossible to completely remove
the mercury from the room.
So this is a problem associated
with the compact fluorescents
that is turning into a rather
interesting and serious dilemma
for waste management.
So not many people really want
to take an old burned out light
bulb back to a recycling center.
In fact, the probability of
getting it there without
breaking it is probably not too
great.
And also, think about again,
plastics and landfill.
An increasing proportion of the
interior built environment is
made up of a variety of plastics
that we've talked about in the
past.
But the extremely low chance
that plastics are going to be
recycled is a logic to rethink
the way that points are
allocated.
There was an interesting debate
inside the Green Building
Council about polyvinylchloride
plastics and whether or not PVCs
ought to be either banned or
whether or not you would have
credits removed if you used PVC,
as opposed to a more recyclable
product like polyethylene,
that most soda bottles are made
out of.
But they decided not to do
that, which is quite curious.
So thinking about the kinds of
materials that are put down on
floors, the sealants also.
This is encouraged.
Credits can be gained if you
choose not just the low VOC
paints, but also the clear
finishes.
Also, you'll find a variety of
products,
including this type of a vinyl
flooring that you could see in
Kroon Hall,
particularly in the stairwells,
that gives off volatile
compounds that I haven't been
able to identify and the
manufacturers are not required
to label.
So think about the variety of
different products that go into
the construction of a building,
and how these products may
change the chemical content of
that environment.
So that the quality of the air
exchange system is really
critical to govern the chemical
exposures that occur.
And this is particularly the
case in a new building.
As an example, rugs.
Rugs may be made out of natural
products, natural fibers,
such as wool or cotton or now
increasingly some reed material
from South America.
But rugs that are made out of
synthetic compounds and their
backing,
many are recommending that
those be aired out in a
warehouse or in a garage for a
period of time,
up to a couple weeks before
they're installed so that
occupants of new buildings would
not be exposed to those fumes.
A couple of other examples that
are not managed by LEED.
Certain golf courses have been
certified.
Whereas the expectation on the
part of the Green Building
Council is that the chemicals
that are used are regulated by
the Environmental Protection
Agency.
And the chemicals that are used
on golf courses are commonly
quite a complex mixture.
And as you remember from the
pesticide section of the course,
many of these have not been
fully tested.
A variety of insulating
materials also can expose
workers at levels that are
potentially hazardous to their
health.
So that some acrylics,
for example,
that play an important role in
increasing the energy efficiency
of a building,
but they can lead to worker
exposure situations.
So thinking about whether or
not LEED should get involved in
concern about the production of
the chemical and its application
and the way that it's actually
used to build a building is
interesting.
LEED has also certified a
bottling plant,
raising kind of an interesting
question.
Well, what if say DuPont
Corporation wanted to build a
plant to produce a variety of
chemicals that were extremely
hazardous,
and perhaps they got into water
or air or soil.
Should they be allowed to get
platinum or LEED certification
for that structure?
Should Nestle be allowed to
gain certification for marketing
products that are not likely to
be recycled?
Here's another example of a
project that was certified in
Florida.
And you remember the lecture
last week about barrier islands.
Well, this owner owns the tract
of land slicing across a barrier
island from the bay to the
shoreline,
and obviously,
has quite intensively developed
it.
You know, seeing the amount of
square footage in homes and the
low occupancy rates has led me
to wonder about whether or not
the government might think about
regulating square foot per
person or cubic foot per person.
I mean, how much space do we
really need per person?
So I'm going to run through
just a few summary of findings
here before I close today that
should give you a sense of
what's working and what's not
working too well with the LEED
program.
These standards have been
designed by a voluntary
nonprofit organization.
But they've been adopted
increasingly at all levels of
government in law.
So they've been added to
Connecticut's laws,
for example.
So that Connecticut now
requires that new buildings that
are going to cost more than five
million dollars need LEED
certification.
Many of the Department of
Energy's programs are now
designed to encourage giving of
grants to projects that gain
LEED certification or would gain
LEED certification.
And many local governments are
now adopting these standards.
So that what's happening here
is that the standards are being
developed by a voluntary
nonprofit organization really to
promote a new form of growth and
development.
But they're being incorporated
wholesale into a variety of
different levels of government
without really thinking
critically about what's working
well and what's not.
There's now no federal
definition of what a green
building standard should be.
Clearly this program gives a
higher priority to energy
efficiency over indoor
environmental quality or human
health.
And if I were going to design a
statute that would encourage
green building,
it would certainly give
increased precedence to public
health concerns and the chemical
content of buildings.
The Green Building Council has
very little expertise in human
health,
and that in part explains why
these standards are not well
developed in that area.
Still, the green certification
program, the LEED program,
gives a false impression of
healthy buildings.
And tighter buildings are more
energy efficient,
but tighter buildings also more
effectively contain chemicals
that get into indoor air.
So that no level of
certification,
even the highest level,
the platinum rating,
assures health protection.
LEED also neglects drinking
water, so that drinking water
supplies are managed in the
nation predominantly by the Safe
Drinking Water Act and the
maximum contaminant level
standards.
So there is no requirement
under LEED to filter water,
despite the fact that many
water lines are capable of
transmitting not just metals but
also some of the components of
plastics.
So that the core problem with
respect to managing chemicals in
the indoor environment and the
ultimate life cycle of chemicals
has to do with Congress's
inactivity,
its failure to demand that
chemicals that are used in the
building industry be labeled,
that they be tested before
they're used.
So that it's creating a pattern
of exposure that really we don't
understand well.
We know we're being exposed to
a brand new mixture of
compounds.
So what kinds of
recommendations might you think
about to improve this system?
Well one would be to simplify
the scoring system so that
rather than using the platinum,
the gold standards,
I would prefer to see a scale
that was simply a zero to one
hundred scale so that people
would not have the incentive
just to get to eighty points so
that that would ensure that they
would be awarded the platinum
certification.
I think that the categories of
certification need to be
diversified so that if the Green
Building Council judged and
scored a project's performance
in separate categories,
developers would have an
incentive to score higher in all
those categories.
In other words,
set up a separate scoring
system for indoor environmental
quality and human health.
Set up a separate system for
energy efficiency.
water supply.
But whether or not we want to
have this system managed by a
nonprofit organization that is
run by the board of directors
that have predominately
for-profit organizations,
that's another basic question.
So should the federal
government take this over?
So this system is not designed
in its current form to encourage
the use of safer chemicals in
the building industry.
So that what kinds of
innovations might encourage
builders to want to buy building
products that contain safer
products?
Well, they would certainly need
to know what the chemicals were
in the products so that there's
a labeling issue that needs to
be confronted.
But also, there's a testing
issue as well.
The Green Building Council also
has the opportunity not to
disclose the results of its
building performance tests.
So that the public really has
no opportunity to hold the Green
Building Council accountable for
its declaration of performance
in different categories.
So I think I'll close with the
thought that this is a very
interesting historical example
of how certification standards
evolved in a nonprofit
organization that really is
representing for-profit
industries,
the large building products
industry,
the major building companies,
large architectural firms and
engineering firms.
And this program has no
accountability at all to the
United States public,
at the same time that it's
being built into law at all
levels of government.
So something seems really very
much out of whack.
And it demands I think a pretty
careful review.
One critical improvement could
be made if minimum performance
criteria were set within each of
the specified categories:
sustainable sites,
energy, the category for indoor
environmental quality.
So that if there were minimum
and protective standards set
inside those categories,
it would go a long way to
meeting some of the objections I
just raised.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
We'll come back to larger
questions of community design on
Thursday.